we have 11 or 12 different student
groups at Harvard hello for for students
to explore their Jewish identity their
spiritual identity or different aspects
of who they want to be we have
everything from from religious prayer
communities to self-defense classes we
have Krav Maga classes we've got a
really wonderful community of social
justice advocates we have we have a
men's group a women's group we have a
queer group on campus we've got a lot of
different really wonderful places that
different the Jews can come and explore
it's also really interesting we find
lots of people who aren't Jewish decide
that Harvard Hill is a wonderful place
to come be themselves as non-jews and do
they just like our community and come
and join us on a regular basis we have a
wonderful tradition at Harvard hello of
Sukkot Salaam we're once a year the the
Jewish students the Muslim students come
together and we we come together in a
cyka cyka is a ritual dwelling place
that we have during the fall and and
Jews and Muslims come together and we we
eat together and we talk about peace
together and when it's a time for our
communities to come and join in immunity
and commitment to peaceful living one of
my favorite parts of my job is to teach
classes I don't teach classes for credit
at Harvard but I do teach for classes
every week and there are a wonderful
place to explore different aspects of
Jewish identity one class I teach is
called Shalom and that's an introduction
Jewish meditation and mysticism it meets
on Thursdays before that I have a new
SAR class where we we talk about
cultivating different spiritual
personality types about how to cultivate
thankfulness in your life how to
cultivate faith how to cultivate
Thanksgiving and we and we get together
and we speak about those things another
class that I that I offer on a regular
basis every Saturday is we have a class
called just kid
that means in place of services for
those of us who don't wake up so early
on Saturday mornings and we we get
together we eat something we drink
something and we we talk about something
justice related in the Torah portion my
last class that I teach is on Wednesdays
and that's a class it's called Jew
curious and that's an introduction to
Jewish life and practice and that's a
and when we come together there every
week it's a different topic and and we
explore what it means to live a
meaningful Jewish life it's really
important to us at Harvard hello there
were a safe space for people regardless
of their sexual orientation of their
agenda their gender identity or where
they're from or their political
orientations people often like to talk
to me about spiritual spiritual dilemmas
that they're having people like to talk
to me about life transitions about
graduating about entering into school
and when that means and also trying to
find a home in the Jewish community of
the spiritual communities at Harvard one
of the things that I do is I hand people
my my card which on one side looks very
official on the back it says it's
redeemable for coffee so if you're
seeing this right now you're welcome to
to come in and we can use this video as
it's redeemable for coffee with me
you